All right, so I just found a faceless
YouTube channel that was created just 2
months ago. Now, the goal of this video
was to see if I can recreate this
channel by using AI. Now, if you want to
learn how to use AI and how to use AI
automation in order to create a YouTube
channel like this one and start your
YouTube journey, in this video I'm
basically going to show you everything.
So, if you want to learn, this video is
for you. So, let's start. Now, once you
have Cloud Code installed on your
computer, go ahead and open Cloud Code
just like this. As you can see, this is
Cloud Code on computer. And what you
want to do is click over here to the top
left on code. Make sure you're not on
co-work, you're not on chat, you want to
be on code. Now, in order for us to be
able to automate the creation of these
videos, we need to install the
Hicksfield skill. For that, I want you
to go back to your browser and search
for Hicksfield over here. Go to
Hicksfield and create an account. Once
you've created an account on Hicksfield,
I want you to click over here where it
says MCP and CLI. Once you click on
this, make sure you click on CLI over
here. Then, what I want you to do is
copy this first command over here just
by clicking on it. Then, over here on
your search bar on your computer, type
terminal like this, terminal, click on
it, and then paste this command over
here and hit enter. Once you hit enter,
it's going to install the CLI. Then,
what I want you to do is go back to
Hicksfield, copy the second command over
here, copy it, go back to your terminal,
and paste the second command and press
enter. It's going to ask you to
authorize access to Hicksfield with your
computer. So, basically, you need an
account on Hicksfield. Then, you have to
go back to Hicksfield and copy this last
command over here, which will install
the Hicksfield skill, which will help us
generate these images. So, copy this
command, go back to your terminal, paste
the command, press enter, and install
the skill. It's really that simple. Now,
I'm not pressing enter because I've
already installed those things, and it's
actually pretty simple. As you can see,
you just copy, paste them, press enter,
press enter, press enter, and that's it.
Now, once you have all of those things
installed, we can start creating the
videos. Now, let me show you how to do
that. Now, what you need is the YouTube
script. Now, depending on what type of
videos you want to make, maybe you don't
want to talk about primitive humans,
maybe you want to talk about space, or
maybe you want to talk about aliens, or
maybe you want to talk about animals.
Depending on your niche, you need a
script. You need to create a script for
the video. Now, what I want you to do is
copy this prompt over here. Let me show
you the prompt.
So, this is the master prompt we're
going to be using. As you can see, the
prompt says, "You are going to generate
images for a YouTube script, one image
for every timestamp in the script." This
is the most important part over here,
which says, "One image for every
timestamp in the script." Over here, it
says, "Your job is to read the script
carefully and create a separate image
for each timestamp. If the script has
timestamps like 0 seconds, 3 seconds, 7
seconds, 10 seconds, 12 seconds, 20
seconds, then you must generate one
image for each of those timestamps."
This is the most important part of the
prompt, right? Because this is what's
going to help us automate the process of
creating these videos. Then, over here,
it says the style requirements, and it
says the image must look like it's
extremely simple beginner drawing made
in MS Paint. It should look like someone
who is not good at drawing created it
quickly by hand, right? This part of the
prompt is also super important because
it's telling Higgs Field how the image
should look like, right? And over here,
we have white background, blah blah blah
blah blah, no 3D, no cinematic, blah
blah blah. This is the entire prompt.
What I want you to do is write a prompt
like this one, or ask ChatGPT or Claude
to write you a prompt like this one. And
after you write this prompt, I want you
to copy this prompt
and then paste it into Claude code. So,
go back to Claude code over here and
paste this prompt in the message box.
Then, what I want you to do is copy the
script with the timestamps and paste it
below this prompt. Now, all you have to
do is send this message to Claude code.
As you can see, Claude code is going to
run the skill over here, and this is the
Higgs Field skill. Then, it's going to
ask you to allow access to the terminal
a bunch of times. You just click allow,
and once that's ready, Claude code is
going to start generating the images. As
you can see over here, running skill
Higgs Field generate, and it's
generating the images. As you can see,
it's asking me to allow access. I don't
think you can see it. Let me Yeah, you
can't actually see it because of my
webcam, so I'm going to take my webcam.
So, as you can see over here, allow once
or allow always. Click always allow.
Right? As you can see, now I'll generate
38 images. Now, it's only going to
generate 38 images because I've copied
just a little part of the script. If you
copy the entire script, it's going to
generate you more than 100 images, which
is absolutely insane. You're You're
basically going to have footage for your
video every few seconds. And this
process over here literally takes you
like 10 minutes. And basically, this is
how it looks. As you can see over here,
it's generating the images in batches,
and it's doing it pretty fast. Now, to
check your images, all you have to do is
go back to your Higgs Field account. So,
back to Higgs Field over here, as you
can see, all you have to do is click
over here at the top left where it says
image. Click on this, and over here, you
should have all the images that are
being generated right now. As you can
see, if I scroll down, we have all the
images for the script. And they have the
exact same style like that channel. So,
if we go back to this channel, and if I
click on one video, let me mute it. I
have YouTube Premium. I have no idea why
I'm receiving ads. So, YouTube is a
little bit sneaky.
As you can see, this is how the videos
look. These are literally just images of
bad drawings. But the secret is that
there's tons of images. As you can see,
the images are changing almost every 2
seconds, almost every 3 seconds. That's
the secret. Now, if we look at the
views, we see that the video was
uploaded literally on April 16, 2026. It
has almost 1 million views, 26,000
likes, almost 3,000 comments, and people
are actually enjoying the videos. And I
can scroll through the video and show
you that all the images look identical.
It's the exact same style we're
generating using Cloud Code and Higgs
Field. If I go back to Higgs Field, we
will see that our images look exactly
the same. We have this image over here.
What else we have? We have these images
over here, right? And what's awesome is
that all these images actually fit with
the script because each image was
generated for a specific timestamp of
your script. Now, let me show you how
you can edit these images super fast.
So, what you want to do is go back to
Claude Code over here, and I'm going to
stop the process of generating these
images. And basically, what you have to
type is link me the folder with the
images, right? And it's going to link
you the folder where all these images
were created, were stored. Now, if you
get this message where it says the
images are generated on Hexfield, hosted
online, not saved locally, you can ask
him to do the following. Please download
these images locally and make their
titles fit with the timestamp. So, if a
an image was created for zero 0.00
seconds, that's the title of the image.
If an image was created for 0:20,
that's the title of the image. This is
super important because having the
timestamps as the title of the image is
what's going to help us create these
videos super fast because we know
exactly where to place them to actually
sync with the voiceover. So, send this
message to Claude, and as you can see,
it's going to create a folder for us,
which is super awesome. Just click
allow, and then it's going to download
all the images for you, which again
automates the work and saves you a lot
of time because even if you have to
download each image, you have to go
click and download, click download. Not
only that, but they don't have the right
titles, and it's going to be hard to
edit them. This way, Claude Code
downloads all the images, but also
changes their titles to fit with the
timestamps. And why that's important is
because we know where to place them on
the timeline when we edit the video. So,
basically, it's going to create you a
folder like this one over here, and as
you can see, inside the folder, all the
images are going to slowly start to be
downloaded. As you can see, this is the
first image, now the second one. So,
basically, how you edit the video now,
it's super straightforward. You open
your video editing program over here,
and if I hit play, you can listen to the
voiceover.
>> Imagine waking up at 2:00 a.m. and not
reaching for your phone.
No glow, no notifications, no
notifications, no clock.
Just absolute darkness.
>> So and now basically based on the title
of the image, this one over here is 0
seconds, you add it until 7 seconds over
here. Because the next image should
start at 7 seconds. As you can see the
the second image says 0.07, which is 7
seconds. Then the third image starts at
0.15 seconds. That means we need to drag
the second image until 15 seconds over
here. We can see over here. Then we're
going to drag the third image and when
is the fourth image going to appear?
It's going to appear at 23 seconds. So
we're going to drag this image until 20
3 seconds. Just like that. Then we add
the next image and we're going to drag
it until 29 seconds because the next
image is going to appear at 29 seconds.
And basically editing the video like
this is going to literally take you 10
minutes. Like it's super easy. AI is
doing most of the work. Now if I hit
play, you will notice how the voiceover
syncs with each image without me needing
to listen to the voiceover and spending
hours thinking and editing. Imagine
waking up at 2:00 a.m. and not reaching
for your phone. Just absolute darkness.
You listen
for 300,000
years.
>> Right. So that's how you can create
these videos by using AI automation. Now
if you're struggling to grow on YouTube,
if your videos get zero views or 50
views or 200 views or they can't get
past 1,000 views, you might want to
watch this video over here because
inside this video I explain why some
channels feel shadow banned. Why some of
you think YouTube is shadow banning you
and literally ignoring your channel. So
if you want to learn about the algorithm
and how to escape that, you might want
to watch this video over here.